today's video is sponsored by raikon
home of wireless earbud designs
inspired by underdogs and big dreams
raycon earbuds start at about half the
price of other premium wireless earbud
brands but they sound
just as amazing as other top audio
brands and they look pretty cool too
check it out these are the everyday e25
earbuds
super soft and flexible to fit different
ear sizes what i'm loving about them is
the seamless bluetooth pairing so i can
easily listen to podcasts and audio
books when i'm on the go
working out and even when i'm at home
and want to take a screen break
but still keep up with the news or chill
out these everyday e25s are good for six
hours of continuous playtime but this
handy case
doubles as a charger and you can
recharge up to four times while you're
out and about
commuting getting some fresh air
wherever life takes you so
if you want a premium earbud offering
quality audio for work or play
at home or on the go give raikon a try
even better
you don't have to take my word for it
raycon offers a 45 day free return
policy now's the time to get the best
prices of the year on raycon's but hurry
this offer is available for a limited
time
only click the link in the description
or go to buyabreakon.com forward slash
visualpolitik to get 15
off your order
[Music]
qatar got off scot-free exactly 43
months after setting it in motion saudi
arabia
the united arab emirates bahrain and
egypt ended the brutal land sea in air
blockade they had imposed on qatar since
june 2017. so on the 5th of january 2021
the politics of the persian gulf marked
up yet another important date in its
turbulent history book
during the 41st annual meeting of the
gulf cooperation council held in the
saudi city of al-uillah the participants
agreed once and for all to put an
end to the commercial and political
blockade on the country ruled by the
house of al-thani it has not exactly
been an easy road for example the crown
prince of abu dhabi the all-powerful
muhammad bin zayed who we have already
talked about on visualpolitik decided
not to attend the council perhaps to
avoid acknowledging the resounding
political failure that the blockade on
qatar has been but why did they decide
to lift it what were the consequences of
this massive boycott why do we say that
qatar got off scot-free
in this video we're going to answer all
these questions but first first we have
to know how and when this whole mess
started
a brutal block
qatar has always been something like the
wayward child of the persian gulf at
least in the eyes of the riyadh
and abu dhabi but to really understand
the origin of this whole story we have
to go back to 2013.
that year then king of saudi arabia
abdullah bin abdulaziz
together with the emirs of kuwait and
qatar at that time
sheikh sabah al ahmed al-jabba al-sabah
and
signed the so-called riyadh agreement
[Music]
the following year bahrain and the
united arab emirates also joined these
agreements under this agreement the gulf
countries pledged not to support or
harbor members of hostile organizations
such as the muslim brotherhood however
as time went on qatar was never seen to
take this agreement very seriously by
its neighbours
this coupled with qatar's good relations
with iran whilst the rest of the gulf
monarchies were frequently subject to
criticism
from al jazeera triggered the events of
4th of january 2017.
[Music]
on that day the united arab emirates
saudi arabia and bahrain
issued an ultimatum either qatar fixed
the situation or they would face a near
total blockade by land
sea and air and that is exactly what
happened on the 5th of january 2017
these three countries cut diplomatic
ties
closed their borders and cancelled sea
routes and access to their respective
airspace they blocked the entry of
qatari citizens and residents into their
own countries
and gave their own citizens 14 days to
leave the blockaded country
[Music]
in fact as hard as it may be to believe
not even the camels were spared
twelve thousand camels grazing on saudi
soil were sent back to qatar
other countries such as egypt the
maldives mauritania
jordan and senegal also joined this
campaign by cutting their relations with
qatar even u.s president donald trump
initially supported the action led by
the uae and saudi arabia despite the
fact that qatar is home to the main uber
space in the middle east
[Music]
so at first the general idea was that
qatar would not take too long to bend
the knee that
is to capitulate to surrender to submit
so how on earth could a small country of
less than 3 million people possibly
survive such a blockade a blockade that
even included some dirty war tactics
it's been leaked that the uae hired
former nsa agents to spy on qatar and
that according to information gathered
by bloomberg it asked the
luxembourg-based bank
javaland to draw up a plan to bleed the
qatari central bank's accounts in order
to force a currency crisis
an action that according to the
complaint made by the qatari government
has cost
it at least 40 billion dollars yes
that's that's right you heard that right
40 billion dollars
[Music]
it seems that the plan designed by the
luxembourg bank consisted of creating a
fund to buy qatari debt and cds's or
credit default swaps insurance policies
against default on that debt
in this way the fund would simulate with
other related funds transactions of
qatari bonds at a decreasing price
and a round trip flow the aim would be
to make the market believe that a
massive outflow
of investors was taking place which
would generate a kind of panic effect
that would lead more and more investors
to liquidate their positions in the
qatari market the outflow of capital
would multiply the supply of the local
currency the qatari vl
forcing the central bank to rescue its
currency by spending billions and
billions of dollars to maintain the
parity between the real and the us
dollar and thus
avoid a run on the banks at the same
time default insurance policies would
rise in price allowing the uae to recoup
a large part of the losses suffered with
the bonds
that is the plan that has been leaked
and although it is not known to what
degree
it was executed what is certain is that
immediately after the blockade was
announced the qatari banking system
suffered a leakage of more than 30
billion dollars which forced the
government to call on the sovereign
wealth fund to come to the aid of the
banking system
qatar's wealth fund returns 20 billion
to qatar to ease
the impact of the embargo deposits
provide liquidity to banks following
neighbors decisions to cut ties
financial times it is clear that the uae
and saudi arabia are
going hard
[Music]
during these years of sanctions qatar
spent close to 40 billion dollars
propping up its currency
and banking system property prices lost
almost a third of their value and
foreign investment plummeted into
negative territory
in other words during each and every
year investment outflows were greater
than inflows but hold on a moment
because three and a half years later the
blockade has been lifted without qatar
fulfilling a single one of the 13
demands made demands that included
shutting down al jazeera distancing
itself from iran
closing any turkish installations in the
country and breaking all ties with the
muslim brotherhood and not only that
saudi arabia and especially the uae have
suffered from the blockade almost as
much as qatar far from achieving their
objectives they have actually provoked
the opposite result
but do you want to know exactly what
happened and how qatar got away with it
well listen up
a different path
according to the plan qatar would bear
the brunt of the blockade and doha would
soon be forced to sit down
and negotiate but wait a minute because
things don't always go according
to plan surprisingly the qatari economy
learned to live with the embargo much
sooner than anyone would have thought
it's true that gdp fell by 1.5 percent
in 2017
yes but for the following two years
growth returned to positive figures and
even in 2020 coronavirus included qatar
has had the least bad performance of all
the gulf countries and is expected to
have the fastest recovery now the
question we need to ask ourselves is how
did they manage to do it well you see
with the overnight blockade as we have
already mentioned the country's main
trade routes were suddenly closed
so a solution had to be found urgently
[Music]
to give you an idea qatar is a country
that relies heavily on foreign suppliers
to meet its daily activities
for example at the time of this
diplomatic crisis it was importing 90
of its food and take note because more
than 40 of all of these imports came
into the country through its land border
with saudi arabia so that gives you the
idea of the scale and urgency
of the problem the qatari government had
to quickly look for alternatives to find
new partners and viable transport routes
as soon as possible
and you know what that's exactly what
they did as we say around here no sooner
said than done
in a way qatar was going to make the
plan back fire on the uae and saudi
arabia
okay but let me repeat the question how
did they pull it off well first of all
if any of you were going to go for a
walk in doha today you would certainly
notice the increasing presence of people
and businesses of turkish
origin faced with the cold shoulder of
its neighbours qatar decided to look for
a new trading partner a sort of
bigger cousin capable of supplying all
the products the country needed while
defending it from a possible military
invasion and that's
exactly what they did with turkey
since 2017 ties between the two
countries have become increasingly close
on the one hand as you can see qatari
purchases of turkish products have
increased
threefold what's more since the
beginning of the blockade turkish
military presence in qatar has increased
tenfold and a second turkish military
base has been opened in the vicinity of
doha
much larger than the first one in return
qatar has boosted its direct investment
in turkey
to become the third largest investor in
the entire country ports
factories hotels financial institutions
both the qatari government and private
investors are investing
and buying all kinds of assets in turkey
and not only that the qatari government
has also come to the rescue of the
turkish government during the worst
moments of the lira crisis
may 20th 2020 qatar pours 10 billion
into alien turkish economy in currency
swap deal ankara once again receives
financial help from close gulf ally as
it battles to contain
rapid depletion of its foreign reserves
me
november 26th 2020 qatar to invest
billions of dollars in turkey amid
currency crisis the qatari government
has signed new investment deals worth
billions of dollars for the turkish
economy
me but it's not just turkey another
country which qatar has forged closer
ties with has been with saudi arabia's
number one arch enemy iran
you see qatar has always had cordial
relationships with the country of the
ayatollahs
among other things because they share
the largest natural gas field in the
world however after the blockade was
imposed tiran set up a sort of airbridge
to supply qatar with
100 tonnes of food a day to avoid a
potential food crisis
and since then commercial ties between
the two countries have increased
four-fold and qatar airways was able to
continue its operations using iranian
airspace in exchange for a commission of
100 million dollars a year
meanwhile the qatari government has also
boosted its relations with both china
and russia for example the qatari
sovereign wealth fund increased its
stake in rosneft the russian state-owned
energy company to 19
an investment that received high praise
from the kremlin as a vote of confidence
in the russian economy
march 11 2019 qatar seeks more russia
deals after
great rosneft investment bloomberg
then at the local level the qatari
government has accelerated the reform
process to gain competitiveness
and reduce its dependence on imports
[Music]
for example changes have been approved
that make it easier for international
investors and entrepreneurs
to achieve residency status in the
country it has been announced that the
jurisdiction of the international court
of qatar will be extended that is
its own legal system based on british
common law will extend beyond the
financial center it has continued to
invest heavily in infrastructure
such as the doha metro and has boosted
the agri-food industry to the point of
achieving self-sufficiency
in areas such as dairy products which
previously were mainly imported from
saudi arabia but take note because the
changes are not limited to the economic
sphere in 2017
the fear of a possible invasion by its
arab neighbours in doha was very intense
that is why they decided to prepare
themselves to prevent it
on the one hand as we have mentioned
ties with turkey was strengthened and it
was agreed that turkey would open a new
military base
a base that was inaugurated in 2019 and
has the capacity to house 5 000 turkish
soldiers
on the other hand kutar has thrown
itself into developing its armed forces
since 2017 it has not only multiplied
its budget but has embarked on a
gigantic military equipment program its
air force for example will go from
having 12 old mirage 2000s to being
equipped with 96 modern fighter jets in
the space of just a few years
this will include 36 french rafale 36
state-of-the-art f-15s and 24 euro
fighters this will make the qatari air
force one of the most formidable in the
world and remember that we're talking
about a country with less than 3 million
[Music]
inhabitants
the bill almost 30 billion dollars but
it's not just aircraft qatar is buying
everything
missiles drones tanks artillery
anti-aircraft devices
patrol boats submarines etc etc cetera
so the result of the blockade three and
a half years after it was launched has
been the exact opposite of that expected
by the uae and saudi arabia
not only has qatar not fulfilled a
single one of the demands made but
instead of distancing itself from iran
and expelling the turkish army as
demanded it has strengthened its ties
with these two countries
to make matters worse qatar is today
economically and militarily
stronger and more autonomous than it was
in 2017. in other words the blockade was
basically a gigantic failure something
that by the way had a lot to do with the
two big heroes of the economy of qatar
the richest country in the world
[Music]
qatar's great stars
qatar has become a natural gas
superpower one of the most fashionable
natural resources in the global economy
in contrast to its neighbors oil plays a
relatively small role here the bulk of
qatar's fortune comes from gas
this small state of just 11 500
kilometers square that's six times
smaller than ireland or
is roughly the size of connecticut is
the world's largest exporter of
liquefied natural gas and has the three
largest proven reserves behind only iran
and russia since the government launched
a strategy in the 1990s to lead the
development of liquefaction technology
that allows natural gas to be exported
in large lng
carriers qatar has continued to invest
in expanding its capacity
[Music]
in fact it is currently immersed in a
plan totaling more than 50 billion
dollars of investment to increase its
production by 40 percent by 2027 and to
have its own fleet of more than 100
huge modern methane tankers to sell its
gas all over the planet
june 3rd 2020 south korean shipbuilders
land 20 billion dollar lng tanker deals
with qatar
asia nikkei review february 9th
2021 qatar approves world's largest lng
project oil price and the truth is that
the prospects are quite good according
to the british consultancy firm wood
mckenzie global demand for liquefied
natural gas will double by 2040. and
here tar's cost advantage makes it one
of the big winners in this growing trend
in fact qatar's investments are not only
limited to its own
country the state-owned energy company
is investing in new fields all over the
world
south africa angola ivory coast cyprus
mexico and so on in addition liquefied
natural gas contracts are often linked
to the price of oil yet
unlike its neighbours qatar only needs a
price of 30 per barrel to balance its
public accounts
in other words on paper its position for
the future seems quite strong
[Music]
within a short time qatari authorities
expect to be able to earn more than 50
billion dollars a year from their
hydrocarbon exports and don't forget
that we are talking about a country with
fewer than 3 million inhabitants and a
population with qatari nationality of
just over 300 000 people in other words
if it achieves its objectives
the country will soon be earning more
than 18 000 per inhabitant per year or
more than 170 000 per citizen with
qatari nationality
crazy on the other hand qatar's second
big star is its sovereign wealth fund
which
year by year has been fattened by oil
and gas profits it's a
huge fund that has more than 300 billion
dollars in investments spread all over
the world
stocks bonds real estate soccer teams
media commodities everything a gigantic
fortune that has become a life insurance
policy for the tiny nation but at this
point we still have one last question to
answer we already know
why the blockade was a failure but why
has it just been lifted at the beginning
of 2021 well listen up
why now
we can highlight three key reasons for
the total suspension of the blockade
first of all the victory of joe biden
until now saudi arabia and the uae had
virtually a free reign with the trump
administration
they got everything they wanted however
now all that has changed particularly in
relation to saudi arabia so let's say
that first of all it was kind of a
goodwill gesture towards the new u.s
administration don't forget that qatar
is a key ally for the united states with
a lot of supporters in washington
but on the other hand in relation to the
political issue there is also the
economic one we have already told you
that saudi arabia is facing an
uncertain economic future its oil wealth
is no longer enough to pay all the bills
and it is precisely here that qatar can
be of great help for example there is
speculation that saudi arabia may start
importing large quantities of qatari gas
in order to reduce its own oil
consumption
and thus be able to increase its crude
oil exports as has already been done
for example by the uae then riyadh also
aims to get investments from the huge
qatari sovereign wealth fund for some of
its huge mega projects with which
it seeks to reduce its dependence on oil
and which we have already covered here
on visualpolitik also don't forget that
improving the political climate usually
helps a lot in attracting international
investors
after all nobody likes to put their
money in places full of conflict and if
there's one thing saudi arabia needs it
is
investment lots of investment so it
seems that these three aspects have a
lot to do with the decision to put an
end once and for all to the brutal
blockade under which qatar has been
punished for
three and a half years but at this point
it's your turn do you think qatar has
really got off scot-free or is it the
uae holding back its last card
and what role do you think joe biden's
administration should play in the middle
east
leave your answers in the comments so i
really hope you enjoyed this video
please hit like if you did don't forget
to subscribe for brand new videos
if you want to learn more about politics
and world affairs and hear some more of
my lovely voice
come check out the reconsidered podcast
where we don't
do the thinking for you find reconsider
at www.reconsidermedia.com or on apple
or google play or your favorite
podcatcher you